thank you for joining us we are here in
the Toyota greenroom with the New York
Times modern love column editor his name
is what's your name Daniel Jones Daniel
Jones you sure that's what it's such a
simple name modern love has become a
Sunday morning tradition of the New York
Times Style section since 2004 and most
recently a podcast sensation we'll talk
about that too who just marked its 100th
episode so since the first column was
published back October 31st 2004 there
have been more than 670 columns in over
80,000 submissions welcome Daniel Downes
thank you I am so glad you're here I'm
gonna try not to drool over you while
we're doing this because I love this
column so much and I think I said here
was a single person which by the way on
the day before balanced on day I sit
here as a single person and I so believe
in the institution of love and every
time I read these columns whether it
ends successfully or it doesn't it just
shows you that loves come love comes in
many forms so take us back to the
beginning what was the premise of the
column when you guys started it what
what you want to do well the style
editor at the time the guy named Tripp
Gabriel who went on to become political
reporter after the Style section he
wanted to have personal stories where
there was enough of a enough words
enough of a narrative arc where you
could really tell a story and suck
people in people and we didn't know what
what the parameters would be but I I
came up with the name modern love from
the David Bowie song I thought that
would make it broad enough to talk about
you know style the star section is about
trends and what's happening now so we
want it to be contemporary and I want to
interpret love as broadly as possible
which you know there's some of the most
moving stories to me are about family
bonds and in parenthood and just those
yes there's those blood bonds that often
are more complicated than yeah it's it's
not always romantic love which I think
is also very interesting and and and I
guess I sit here because I so love the
idea of love and when I look at your
columns I'm wondering even if it doesn't
have a happy ending there's always a
moment in the story where you go you
know they just sort of gets
right here is that the intention - to me
to me a story is happy if it leads to
greater understanding you know you can't
really change tragic things are gonna
happen you know but that doesn't really
make for a sad story as long as you a
sad story for me as someone who doesn't
know anything more at the end of the
story at the beginning you know that's
that sad yeah someone who who learns who
can be useful to others who can who can
understand something at a deeper level
and you know I read so many of these and
I get bored so easily with the
submissions that are coming in that that
when someone really really identifies
something and talks about a problem in a
new way it just stands out what is the
process of selecting the story is it
just you sitting at a desk and you're
reading very boring it's very boring at
all it's me and a laptop or a desktop
and just scrolling sort of blindly
through and is it really just submission
doing it it was me alone for the first
12 years when we started the podcast it
more submission started coming in and I
had an intern that I'd used when I'd
done college contests who was really
good and so she she now helps it's all
kind of far I merrily the only way to
find the good material is to read
everything that's that's the lesson that
is true I learned that I was asked to
judge the Tribeca Film Festival the
short stories years ago the short films
years ago and somebody said well you
know you can just look at the first five
minutes you don't have to look at the
whole thing but I think that doesn't
injustice if you don't because who knows
it could turn so I sat there and looked
at every single one and at times it does
become tedious so I was wondering what
that process is like for you so what
grabs you right away where you go okay
we're onto something do you have to be
grabbed by the first line no okay but if
someone you can tell right away if
someone is is vulnerable on the page if
they're if they're being honest and if
they're if they're grappling with
something rather than trying to show off
with words you can tell that
it's really quickly and a lot of the
kind of show off the stylistic voice
kind of thing but if someone has been
through something that has been
profoundly moving to them and has
changed them you can see that in the
words whether they can pull that off in
an essay that that grows and and you
know that they really learn from that's
another matter but but you can tell that
voice you can tell that reality pretty
quickly
we're talking to Daniel John Souza style
editor the New York Times for the modern
love that the editor for the modern love
column in The New York Times one of my
favorite things about the Sunday paper
so let's talk about first lines cuz this
grab me where does this stand for you in
your definition I had invited him over
for only sex so when I woke up the next
morning the sight of him putting on his
pants I said do you need me to walk you
out I thought I want to finish that and
this is and the headline is for the best
hook-up results use your words okay
question mark yeah this is a 24 year old
you know that the way the way kids
approach relationships has has changed
in ways and this was one of these about
you know we're sort of wandering into
casual sex and having it become more
complicated and those stories can really
can really resonate because as so many
people are finding themselves in those
situations these days no and you know
they had sex on the first date and then
she writes and she never saw him again
which goes back to what your mother used
to say never have sex on the first date
they go why buy the cow when you develop
for free yeah but I think that that's
changed though in this era where I've
talked to a lot of young people that say
you know if I have sex on the first date
I don't necessarily judge that person if
I really like them are you finding that
attitudes have changed and I think women
feel like if if men can be in you know
can date for that purpose then then we
can I see that women have a harder time
with it still yeah and and that came
through in this piece where the guy I
mean she was questioning this guy's
behavior because he
kept flattering her he said over-the-top
yes it's like this old-school courting
you know like you you're you do you're
everything to me and blah blah blah and
then and then he ghost sir after I'll
call you later yeah you know how many
times will you say well what does leader
mean does it mean two hours does it mean
tomorrow does it mean next week the
other thing that I love about the calm
so much are the headlines that you
choose let's see one is what Shamu
taught me about a happy marriage the
bike that saved my life how 30 blocks
became 30 years and this one just for
tonight pretend you don't know how much
thought yeah and last weekend how much
thought goes into the headlines that you
choose for the columns
well the headlines are so important
these days and what to do what drives
that a lot is social media you know if
most most of the people who come to
modern love come through through social
media and all they get whether it's on
Twitter or on Facebook is a headline the
graphic and a few words underneath that
and that's everything that's going to
make them click or not but it can't be
clickbait it has to deliver and it has
to be provocative it has to capture the
story but it can't give too much away
it's got to be honest so we yeah we go
over and over he said like sometimes
they come quickly and sometimes we go
and the illustrations too were also to
me another important part of it number
one there's a very distinct style do you
always use the same artist it's been the
same artist Brian Ray for like the past
eight years brian has a very distinct
style on this column and what what
always fascinates me is when I look at
the illustration I wonder how in the
world is this going to make sense a with
the headline on the story and it always
delivers is a lot of time also spent on
the illustration because I think that's
key to to the success that's interesting
for me to hear because I I don't
approach any of this fresh like I'm part
of a creative process so when I see the
picture it immediately makes sense to me
because I know what it is yeah but he's
just a sort of a brilliant artist and
and he has this this palette of colors
that are
sort of bright and stand out and and a
childlike style of stoma stick drawing
at times that was but yeah he just got
this he comes up with several sketches
that are just pencil on paper and he
sends though sometimes it's for
sometimes it's six and the art director
and I will decide sort of which which
works the best and then he'll he'll
follow through with color now do people
just randomly submit things to you or
you out soliciting for ideas they
randomly submit there about eight
thousand a year yeah and how long does
it take you to make a decision on I'm
gonna choose that one because I'm
thinking you're never gonna run out of
material here probably not no sometimes
within the first read but a surprising
number I really have to really have to
stew over and sometimes I need to edit
it before I can tell if it works or not
and sort of pair away words and shape to
make sure it was like well yeah what is
there such a thing as the most popular
modern love column because I definitely
have one yes what is it it was so-called
to fall in love with anyone do this oh
yeah it's about 36 questions yeah I took
those questions yeah a lot of people
drew my imaginary friend a lot of people
did like 20 or 30 million people so that
one just went went all over the place
did you and your are you married I'm
married married I think I'm the only
person who didn't do those questions how
long have you been married 25 years so
you and your wife do you didn't do it we
didn't that was kind of afraid for some
reason I'm not very brave what are you
afraid of afraid of the truth speak into
the microphone my favorite one was you
may want to marry my husband mmm I
thought this was one of the most
touching things I've ever read
yeah this was a woman who was dying and
he was dying and she was talking about
she talked so loving lovingly and so
kindly about her husband the man that he
was a man that he is
and I thought she set it up so
beautifully and I was hoping well maybe
she'll survive she didn't she died ten
ten days after ten days after it was
published what was her reaction to that
one that but that's still my favorite
one it was a profound reaction I mean it
just it was a sob fest around the world
that was an interesting story because it
it came in to the inbox and she was in
very tough shape already she was in
Hospice and it sat there for a week
unread because I didn't know was the
hair and then and then her agent sent it
to a different editor and it got to me
and when we worked on we when were in
editing the piece she was you know she'd
have to pause a long time for breath by
the time it was the saddest part about
that is we and we've rushed into the
publication and even so she wasn't her
agent told me she wasn't quite aware
when it came out she you know she was
really just days from dying at that
point but it was such a gift to her
family yeah that's it was so such a sort
of beautiful and and her husband didn't
know about it she was doing
did he do you know if he got married
again I don't know I don't have an
update on here you know don't you think
we need an update on that story we do
you know this is just March third 2017
but I was very curious I'd be very
curious to see what happened to him and
the response that he got after his wife
was encouraging women to fall in love
with her husband who she thought was
really outstanding you know so as we as
we celebrate Valentine's 2018 what do
you want to tell us about the state of
love in this country or the state of
love among people in general are we
taking it seriously do we still care
about it well yeah of course we care
about it because I have a friend of mine
who says the institution of marriage is
dead you know people are hooking up
people aren't really looking for
substantial relationships and I just
don't happen to think that that's true
that's why I'm asking you I think I
think the biggest challenge these days
is the
you know you have to make yourself
vulnerable to to be open to another
person to be open to love to you you
have to be a sucker you know and not
good it's it's guilt it's the only way
to do it in this case yeah but you know
technology and our phones and dating
apps and all that that all you can use
them as kind of a shield you know to
keep to keep yourself at a distance from
people and to not take risks you know
with especially with college kids today
it's like the the way to ask someone out
is to text like what's up I know I hate
that people don't pick up the phone and
call yeah and even picking up the phone
and calls it's more of a risk you're
putting more of yourself out there but
you can be rejected more to your face in
that way so that I think that's the
biggest hurdle I find people are as
romantic as ever but less willing to
take risks and so it becomes sort of a
conundrum like how do you somebody texts
you and says what's up that's their way
of asking you out yeah really cuz we're
sex so we're asking for sex I got one of
those texts the other day and I thought
they really wanted to know what's up I
said oh I'm working on a piece I'm
working that I don't know it depends on
the context I didn't know what's up he
was asking me out on a date I didn't
realize that you probably master at 25
yeah what's up I'm like well let's see
I'm getting ready to fly here I see I
don't know that I don't know the queues
who is who is harder to fall in love
men or women well that's an interesting
question because men are more likely to
say I love you first this was a big
surprise to me that's a big to me I
think it's seven seventy percent of the
time men say I love you first but they
say it before that you've had sex
they said before you but like before
you've had sex with the person and then
the woman is more likely to say I love
you after sex and then the man's not as
interested you know what's worse is if
you say I love you and you hear crickets
I know
or thanks or yeah that's or or that's so
nice so men are likely before sex to say
I love you
yeah that's interesting to study the
done Penn State University and women are
more likely to say it after yeah and
then by then the man is asleep so you're
thinking as we celebrate Valentine's Day
that love still really matters please
say that I mean I I find the younger
generation like deep I find them deeply
cynical and deeply romantic at the same
time it's sort of the more more polar
extremes they fantasize I mean we held a
college essay contests and what comes up
as an influence on love in relationships
more than anything else our Disney
movies yeah and they stick but they're
aware like this is not the truth this is
not this is a fantasy but they still
there's like this powerful you know
drive to believe in that kind of love I
still have the keep hope alive that's I
still have the keep hope alive thank you
so much Daniel don't I love love love
your work love this calm can't wait to
see what happens on Sunday bye thank you